Hey, in this video you're gonna have a look and explore
what is this concept called hallucinations.
We'll look at what hallucinations are
and how you can avoid them when you're using large language
models such as ChatGPT.
Firstly, hallucinations are basically some type
of factually incorrect text that has been created
by the LLM or the large language model.
Large language models are simply predicting the next token
and therefore they can often produce
factually incorrect text.
There was a study done in 2022 about ChatGPT
was creating non-factual references
within the science community and this could be
a really large problem in areas like law and healthcare.
So let's have a look at an example inside of ChatGPT
where we're telling it to create some fake
or hallucinated content and how we can tell
ChatGPT to avoid hallucinating.
So you can see here we've had a prompt,
who was the first man to visit to Jupiter
and I've just said, make something up.
This is obviously not factual, it's not correct.
Now, obviously I've had to say something like
make something up but there will be scenarios
where you ask ChatGPT something and it will come up
with something that's not technically true.
How can we get over that?
How can we ground ChatGPT in some knowledge
that either is at your own company
or your personal information?
So I'm gonna give you a technique
that you can use for this.
So I'm gonna go to Google and type digital marketing
and I'm gonna take some information here
and this could be, you might be using information
from your own company or it could be a PDF.
I'm gonna create a new chat, I'm gonna triple quotes
and then I'm gonna paste this information in like this
and I'm gonna say I want you to answer
the following query by only referencing
the documents above in triple quote characters
if you don't have an answer,
simply respond with I don't know, right?
And then we can ask ChatGPT what is the weather, right?
And basically you'll see that we've now grounded
ChatGPT in some knowledge, right, from the internet.
So we could also say what is social media marketing?
And what you'll see is that the knowledge
that was contained within those triple quotes
was actually factually grounded
based off some information that I chose to ground it in.
So this is a way where if you've got some company information
or you have some specific documents
or certain types of knowledge,
you could put that inside triple quotes
and you can say to ChatGPT,
I only want you to answer from this knowledge
and then you're grounding ChatGPT
in not knowledge that it knows internally
but knowledge that you've decided is important
for answering your question.
So this is one common use case and technique
that you can use to overcome hallucinations
for when factual consistency
is really important in the answers.
Another way that you can factually ground a reference
inside of ChatGPT is adding a file to a conversation.
For example, we can go and hit the plus button here
and then go to add photos and files.
I'm gonna put a file that you can download
in this lecture to follow along with.
Gonna go and download a digital company profile
and then I'm gonna say,
what is the company Aurora?
And because you've added a file,
you can ground ChatGPT to answer specifically
from that documentation.
You can add lots of different files
and also images directly inside of ChatGPT
to help sure that it doesn't hallucinate.
In the next video, we're gonna have a look
at the difference between two types of models
that have come out recently.
So there is ChatModels, which are the older type of models,
the newer type of models, which are reasoning models,
and we'll look at the differences between those two
and how you can get started with them.
Cool, see you in the next one.